hello everybody and welcome to let's
play Anna alright if you're looking it's
a rather sunshiny and beautiful game but
this is actually a horror game I know
that kind of threw me off too I opened
it up and it was like huh
but no this is a horror game that people
have been suggesting to me so I'm gonna
give it a try
got all the music volume down also
recording it separately so let's give it
a go I think I remember someone sent me
a trailer of this I still recall the
ecstasy of the Sun piercing through the
trees okay
while our hours elapsed along with the
chant of the wind blowing across the
mountains I hoped I had forgotten you
forever and ever
Anna Anna my love Wow oh holy crap
too much mouse mouse is too much it's
the house to keep appearing keeps
appearing in my nightmares yeah this is
really Brown no doubt I could count each
individual crevice how did I always end
up here I mean man this is bright and
vibrant closable but I'm beyond the
gates by now I must found out find out
why I keep dreaming of her I'm in dire
need of answers interesting well this is
made in the Unity engine I believe and I
got a I can't go to menu or I'll just
live with the mouse for now but
eventually I want to change that because
it's way way way too but I'm so pro at
all it was firmly bolted shut
I cannot get that I can't use it
Sacre the water is pristine and inviting
well let's up and non-cancer can you
jump
is he gonna closer crystal clear surface
almost makes you thirsty okay that's not
a door now there's that named door to
the sawmill but it seems to be bolted up
it's shut no kidding alright I don't
know why the mouse is defaulted to
extreme Oh quake 3 Pro all right it
won't budge of course like everything
else in every horror game I can't to use
it the window is firmly bolted shut
all right so that's voltage shot that's
voltage shun what's this ah a little
door
it's like amnesia can click-and-drag I
see a hand it closes a small space under
the staircase Gaming crunch
I'll see you scratch use holy crap I am
going to pull out my hair it makes me so
uncomfortable when I can't click on
something and I'm trying to it's like
the most uncomfortable feeling in the
world
alright
a huge rock is blocking the small
channel what's going on here all those
dark and murky someone there okay
oh man I hate having the wrong
sensitivity just know it's it's huge
bothers you in the back of the mind Oh
My lordy Lou okay maybe I'll do this way
nope nope I thought maybe but no stick
there we go I have a stick now what to
do with this stick I would love to get
do I have an inventory screen yes I do
ah this would have been helpful a while
ago okay
wooden branch so let me use it seems
durable well then it's like an old
school why would I do that because
you're a douche
that's why come on now no way ha no way
hmm yep this is definitely me playing
hotel and there we go
all right God there's something under
the water there yeah yeah there we are
there it is the water is cleaner now
oh come on let me near shark pick up
there we go oh maybe I could use it
maybe you use a knife on the string I'll
probably make more sense right
ah there it is I'm an idiot I've managed
to pick up two pebbles what does that
even mean why I have an empty cam teen
let me fill up my canteen with water the
flask is filled gray how did that do for
me mmm yeah I continue to carry with me
all right
I can burn things burn I am going to oh
I'm going to kill someone
I'm going to kill someone I am going to
stab in face I am going to murder their
face off I'm going to murder someone's
face off I am going to destroy
everything I see everything I hold dear
will be destroyed because I can't figure
out the first freaking level of this
game I cannot and it is the worst it's
the worst
I'm the worst apparently is awful
fantastic and I'm a dumbass ah you're
right click your right click your right
click you right-click the Frick frakking
thing you like click it you I need to
find a light I have a light in my
frickin dare we go ah you gotta be
joking me
oh you're right clicking you're right
click it you're right
click the yeah get it ok maybe that's my
fault for being like thinking that left
liking would do anything but no
apparently not it stuck to the wall okay
now I have two mirror shards and
probably come on use on that what what
can't I can't I why can't I do that I
guess it didn't help me progress I
thought maybe I could get in somehow get
in that way
what's that ah oh ah oh ah oh ah oh ah
ding bang bada bada bing bang okay jump
cut okay ah I found
I fixed the mouse I faxed it I fixed it
but I don't know what's going on cuz
effects it but it didn't fix my brain I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what oh hey yeah pikas awesome what why
why pinecones why pinecones why
pinecones
why why why why pinecones why why why
pinecones why particles why
seriously why why did I need that many
pinecones easy to light a fire is it to
light a fire use it - can I burn the
door down please
oh jab it in the eye I make it a pupil
that's totes it man
that's totes it because that makes sense
really oh ha ha
whatever now I light it on fire is that
what I do I hate I hate my life I hate
my life ah why did that do that why that
do that why do what why why that do I
should extinguish them I'll extinguish
it with my water canteen I'm gonna fill
it up again
I want my Wawa it doesn't work what ah
you son of I will I will destroy your
face that's not the source of the fire
the eyeballs the sorts of the friggin
fire you're the source of a thousand
pains in my ass there we are
I'm gonna get more Wawa you go shove
shove a pine cone up your pot drop a
pine cone up Lobo all right
Lasky's field I go in now please Oh Oh
glory day finally I get all candles and
the lamp has been led to someone's still
living here hello what's this den
there's something there's something
written on it
obsessed by such beauty he stretched out
his arm and cut himself with the heated
blade at last he had fulfilled the right
only when he had seen his own blood
pollute the limpid water he realized he
was drawing the truth ok or cans do I
need to pick up the cans too broken
table the Hilty stock we free with a
solid blow with my fist or my face
hello chair ok I can use this yes I can
you're a liar yeah oh whoa area oh don't
play with me man
I understand enough truth I know that
you're a [ __ ] and I hate you really
weak rail light can't use it it's
awfully dark wish I had a lantern so
that's not a funnel that is not a puddle
for reform perhaps that is very deep I
fear nothing
fear your ugly face that I'm sorry meat
grinder
hmm okay um pickup yeah okay I'll just
get some sawdust is flammable examine
okay huh that was cool touch the fire
taught you to fire there's something in
the flock good thing I have an empty
canteen really you kidding me maybe this
will work yeah no that would like
explode into a million million births a
plane hello Boz well I can't I don't get
you can't use it okay that's a bloody
cloth there's a ladder over there and a
door of some type no oh come on
oh no oh are you not opening or am I
just totally ridiculous here why is this
not working perhaps with a local
children yeah I'm sure not some
diabolical monster whose children
diabolical monster children maybe come
on oh my god this is gonna be a long
first episode I want to get to the
scares so that you're not all thinking
like oh good game thug
sure is dark sir hello hello Oh what's
this hello
what was that okay
okay what's going on here what's with
this door I have anything they can open
the door maybe a stick guy use it two
together throw the sawdust at it
something moved it makes no sense you
don't make any sense I don't know I
don't know I don't know I might I might
like I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know I don't know I don't
know I don't know what's in here aah aah
come on that's a drawer isn't it that's
a drawer come on that's a drawer
oh it's been locked I'm gonna pick it
can imagine yeah I think I don't think
you'll work okay it's locked all right
um man this is a bunch of little things
this really is old-school style
slow exploration try everything on
everything sort of game okay there's
nothing over here oh there's another way
another walkway oh no it's a big circle
can I go in the water oh maybe I can oh
the canteen on the water
I'm so stupid oh I'm so stupid why
couldn't I just carry it with me from
outside in maybe it's a ghost can't
eating it dumped itself out okay
yeah there we go and that's the key to
the drawer come on gimme gimme gimme
gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme gimme
ah hey know that forever and ever
okay leaves what a shot what is that a
wooden box
okay I got a heap of dry leaves this
door is still closed okay
okay I think that might be enough for
now
oh yeah
that's enough for now okay I'm gonna
cutter here thank you guys so much for
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next part
bye bye